notre deuxième sujet ce soir william
taylor
l'ambassadeur américain en ukraine cet
ancien combattant au vietnam et cheveux
gris le visage sévère il a ouvert hier
le bal des auditions publiques menées
par la chambre dans le dans le cadre de
l' ukraine l'ukraine gates est difficile
à prononcer l'ukraine get on rappelle
que les démocrates soupçonnent le
président américain d'avoir voulu faire
pression sur le tout jeune fraîchement
élu président ukrainien pour obtenir de
lui l'ouverture d'une enquête sur son
principal rival joe biden alors les
démocrates espèrent aussi par ces
auditions montrer au grand jour toutes
les turpitudes de trump mais pour
l'instant les auditions ont surtout mis
en lumière le franc soutien des
républicains
on écoute en tout cas les commentaires
de trump alors il a encore d'autres
arguments on écoute à nouveau alors tout
est très simple richard wehrli est-ce
que c'était un bon pari cette procédure
d'impeachment politiquement oui pour les
démocrates effectivement il avait besoin
de d'un moyen majeur pour déstabiliser
trump et ses preuves lui-même qui leur a
servi ce moyen sur un plateau donc il
est évident que du point de vue de
stratégie politique on va voir et ça
pèse déjà lourd aujourd'hui à washington
par contre moi je peux pas m'empêcher
d'être bluffé par la défense demain
quand on a un tel aplomb
quand on est capable de mentir à ce
point à son propre peuple alors je ne
sais pas ce qui peut en sortir c'est
vrai que franchement ça terrifie mai
malgré tout le sénat est complètement
oui alors il faut quand même attention
c'est dur qui ne peut pas aboutir alors
c'est une procédure c'est ce qu'on
répète sans cesse mais n'oublions quand
même pas qu'à un moment donné il ya six
lits à d4 conscience qui se posent tous
les hommes politiques américains n'ont
peut-être pas envie que leurs destins
soyez à donald trump et je ne mettrais
pas ma main au feu sur l'existence
éventuelle d'un point de bascule est ce
qu'à un moment donné si les accusations
sur ce qu'on entend lors de ses
auditions publiques devient tellement
fort est ce qu'un certain nombre de
sénateurs républicains ne vont pas se
dire que ils ont peut-être un autre
destin que celui d'accompagner leur
président je pose la question
l'arithmétique simple puisque je crois
qu'il faut deux tiers du parlement dans
son ensemble pour voter cette procédure
ça ça paraît totalement impossible alors
après vous savez moi je vais un peu de
la politique faisons de la politique
cription si jamais cet échange entre un
ancien animateur de l'émission de télé 1
fraîchement élu acteur a donné cette
espèce de série assez incroyable de dire
tiens fait une enquête sur d'opposants
et puis je te donnerai une aide et
peut-être quelques armes fait parler la
planète entière si ça peut permettre
de pousser en marge de la deûle à
l'élection du représentant démocrate en
ce moment monsieur byden et de mètres et
de renforcer la candidature d'elizabeth
warren est de faire en sorte que les
américains
en quelques mois nous élisent la
première femme présidente des états unis
et qu'on balaye 7 cette période de
quatre ans et bien si ça peut avoir
cette vertu j'en serai ravi
au-delà de ça encore une fois vous avez
vu sur la santé jean je vous ai dit
attentisme je vous ai normes et le
militantisme pense que maintenant il ya
des gens qui ont défendu trois poteaux
débuts en dix ans il représente une
certaine amérique et puis c'est vrai que
quand vous avez quelqu'un qui ce matin
vous dis d'erdogan c'est very good guys
voyez même si à un moment où vous dites
il ya de la géopolitique derrière un
moment on se disent ça suffit on n'en
peut plus mais au-delà de ça je vous
disais pour la santé on est tous
responsables
ce pays m'a quatre mois depuis 10 ans ce
pays les créationnistes c'est à dire qui
vous expliquent que les dinosaures
eh bien ça a été créé dans les évangiles
c'était ce pays il pensa quasiment une
personne sur dix que la terre est plate
ce pays il commence à avoir des valeurs
hallucinante qui le transforme petit à
petit en espèce de dictature de la
pensée et elle est indécente
politiquement mais si regardez ce qu'a
rapporté aux noms mais je peux dire ces
gens là au telus donald trump et un
moment c'est bien de frapper sur donald
rome il ya quand même une partie de cet
électorat qui est assez inquiétant et
moi je suis inquiet par ce pays parce
que dans les vidéos pardon si on se met
une seconde dans la peau de l'américain
moyen
et ça rien de péjoratif mais qu'est ce
qu'ils voient l'américain moyen ils
voient se présente dans le public dit le
président qui dit je me batte pour vous
avec cet aplomb effectivement dont on
parlait et puis qu'est ce qu'ils voient
ils voient que les créations d'emplois
on fait baisser le chômage à un niveau
jamais atteint depuis 1969
il ya eu 170 mille créations d'emplois
au mois d'août cent quarante mille au
mois de septembre des américains qui
étaient plus sur le marché du travail
depuis la crise financière qui
retrouvent un emploi le taux de chômage
des hispaniques se dit le droitiste je
voudrais bien avoir donald trump comme
président et son taux de chômage mais
oui c'est ça
les hispaniques ont jamais eu un taux de
chômage aussi faible depuis 40 ans nous
on se met voilà dans la peau de
l'américain alors certes il ya des
incertitudes créées par la guerre
commerciale
il ya cette affaire qui pour l'américain
moyen louis maurat le monde as pas
terrible mais en même temps je sais pas
très bien ce que c'est mais il ya les
américains qui ont voté pour un
président qui est en train de créer les
conditions pour que chacun ait un emploi
et puissent éventuellement payer le
crédit de sa voiture à la fin du mois
vous en pensez ce que je sais c'est un
peu moins tranché richard par exemple
parce que derrière l'histoire de bourhis
ma tête il ya quand même une histoire un
petit peu compliqué pour les démocrates
l'histoire c'est quoi c'est que bourhis
ma tête une très grosse société
d'extraction de gaz qui sont déjà un peu
le souffre puisque son directeur qui
s'appelle nicolas jault sheepskin ce que
je vivais n'atteint ne peut plus être en
ukraine est toujours dirigé la société
mina dirige de l'extérieur il était mis
sa déco de l'écologie sous ianoukovitch
et c'est quand et nikki beach était
premier ministre puis président qu'il a
eue les licences d'extraction de l'entré
deux tours de la fin la région on est
obligé de rentrer dans son affaire parce
que les états unis sont toujours
beaucoup teintes sombres sont beaucoup à
ta venue en ukraine depuis 1991 pour
donner des subventions des aides pour
aider à la reconversion des colonies et
aussi pour lutter contre la corruption
or au moment où
il ya du coc vite j'étais à la barre
pendant ce temps là le fils de joe biden
qui est le futur plus grand le candidat
le plus crédible contre trump la
prochaine course à la maison blanche et
est membre du conseil d'administration
de cette société
donc et que si c'est passé il sait pas
c'est que dans le cadre de la lutte
contre la corruption que l'ukraine
mettait en oeuvre aussi pour être le
meilleur élève des états unis un
procureur de la république saisit de la
sphère bourhis mans et a commencé à
enquêter
joe by dane a dit dans une vidéo qu'il
voulait la peau de se procurer de la
ligne viktor choutkine et qu'ils ne
verseraient pas 1 milliards de
subventions à l'ukraine
tant que tu viktor choutkine serait en
place donc oui c'est compliqué quand
même parce que les démocrates ont mis
les pieds dans un cadeau quelque chose
ou forcés où ils vont pas forcément en
ressortir leurs pieds aussi problème
pour ça que rudy je viens de passer
beaucoup de temps là bas on a des
réseaux parallèles qu'il met en pleine
démocratie y est diplomatie parallèle
c'est ce qu'ont dit les deux
intervenants toutefois gru qui vient
quand même un sujet fils de joe biden et
il ya un sujet interventions des jobs
hayden dans la peuge justice ukrainienne
pour faire stopper lé enquête qui visait
cette société société qui n'est pas si
clair que ça il ya un problème de
corruption en ukraine il ya des
gouvernements qui à chaque foyer à
nouveau gouvernement y mette en place
une politique de lutte contre la
corruption qui c'est vrai c'est rossi a
tapé en interne sur leurs adversaires
mais on voit que les américains et ça
c'est sa date d'avant trump ont toujours
grâce à l'argent utilisé la fin qu'il
donnait à l'ukraine pour essayer
d'influencer les différents quais dames
emmenées dit les démocrates ont le tort
ça va se retourner contre eux je dis que
c'est pas si pire que ça c'est pas si
simple que ça parce que d'ailleurs dans
l'angle est on est on chercha à savoir
ce qui s'est passé au cours de ces
conversations téléphoniques il ya un
deuxième volet qu'il déterminer si le
fait d'avoir demandé ça avait quelque
chose de mal diront ne pars pas du
principe que le fait d'avoir demandé
c'est quelque chose de mal donc je crois
qu'il faut se méfier d'abord ils
n'obtiendront pas gain de cause pour des
raisons
comptable mais surtout il risque d'avoir
un jeu du boomerang sur ce coup là oui
quand même rappeler deux choses là comme
ça la commission denquête elle a pour
but de démontrer si le pour résumer à
l'extrême si le président des états unis
a outrepassé ses pouvoirs et à chercher
à établir une diplomatie parallèle à son
service et au service de sa réélection
c'est ça le sujet c'est pas de dénouer
s'il ya un scandale de corruption en
ukraine c'est de savoir est ce que je
serai zidane trump a utilisé le réseau
diplomatique américain au profit de sa
candidature ça c'est quand même
l'opinion elle se joue et ensuite pour
répondre à ce que disait marie alors
c'est vrai que l'américain moyen voit
l'emploi voit le crédit de sa voiture
qu'il pourra payer mais de grâce les
américains moyens voient aussi leurs
institutions
ils ont aussi le respect de leurs
institutions et ils ont aussi des
raisons de s'inquiéter sur leurs
institutions
donc ne prenons pas les américains
simplement comme des citoyens obsédés
par leurs fins de mois
il est un grand pays ce sont des grandes
institutions c'est une grande démocratie
est aujourd'hui pas mal de gens ont des
raisons de penser que cette démocratie
peut être menacée j'ajoute juste que
donald trump rappelons le toujours a
quand même perdu le vote populaire face
à hillary clinton
3 millions d'âmes de devoir en peluche
pour hillary clinton
c'est le système électoral américain qui
fait qu'il est aujourd'hui à la maison
blanche après juste un petit point et
marc il le sait très bien
faut toujours prendre avec beaucoup de
mesure les chiffres du chômage aux
etats-unis parce que les américains
comme d'autres pays ont un travail de
leur population active ils sortent tous
les gens qui sont soit disant handicapés
choses comme ça et ça fait des dizaines
de millions de personnes
donc des inégalités hallucinante mais
vous avez tout à fait raison les gens
voient alors je suis pas très
honnêtement je ne suis pas politique et
je ne reproduirai pas l'erreur dé larry
clinton de dire que ceux qui votent pour
poindre sur des déploiements gaulle
parce qu'elle a perdu l'élection
en faisant cette faute politique
hallucinant je pense qu'il ya une grande
partie de l'électorat de donald trump
qui le connaît pas son pays qui n'a
aucune culture qui ne connaît pas son
histoire et qui est incapable de juger
de ce qui se passe en ce moment que ce
soit à l'extérieur le territoire ou même
de la façon dont les institutions sont
gérés la parka par carmine valentin
demptos ne suis pas les auditions parce
que je suis pas toutes les solutions
est ce vous est pris 2 c'est de savoir
si l'europe avait cherché à conditionner
des actes officiels
une réception la maison de lens où
l'assistance militaire américaine à la
coopération d'ukraine à deux enquêtes
politiques qui le concernait mais une
fois le plus gros joe biden dit je
conditionne le versement de 1 milliard
de dollars
au fait que le procureur dégage il a
fait la même chose
ben oui non mais vous comprenez on ne
peut pas se prévaloir de sa propre
turpitude les internautes
il fallait bien quelqu'un qui sommes
trump bouscule les codes d'une société
bien pensante qui veut être bien vu donc
quelqu'un qui est plutôt pour 30
babineau les chiffres de l'économie
était plutôt bon sur obama aussi c'est
dans la continuité trump n'a pas
bouleversé le système
voilà nous avons une opinion partagée
comme vous autour de la table notre
troisième sujet ce soir ils ne pourront
pas dire qu'ils ne savaient pas ça c'est
l'argument utilisé par les promoteurs
d'un nouveau mis tous